Carla Bruni première dame de France tous
les chanteurs s'envoient seront décorés
Stéphane Guillon
bonsoir
bonsoir Stéphane
Guillon pour la semaine de
[Applaudissements]
week-end dernier Disneyland Paris
proposé un nouveau compte de Noël il
était une fois un président fragilisé
par la visite en son palais d'un sale
type très moche pour oublier sa
déconvenue Nicolas pria la princesse
Carla de l'accompagner à la parade de
Mickey tour de manège et nuit enflammée
à l'hôtel Bambi suite panpan
le sourire de Carla pourrait effacer la
triste mine de Kadhafi c'est très fort
attention toutefois à la surenchère si
Sarkozy reçoit Ben Laden pour faire
passer la pilule il devra se taper Loana
à l'Aquaboulevard
[Applaudissements]
Nicolas est très fier de sa nouvelle
conquête regardez cette photo après
Vincent Perez Charles Berling mi Jagger
Éric Clapton
[Applaudissements]
le président ne pense qu'à Carla même
quand il parle politique ses mains le
trahissent on n'a pas couché ensemble le
premier soir
on a fait ça le troisième soir dans une
position très classique celle du
missionnaire
[Applaudissements]
car la Bruni une amoureuse effrénée en
2000 elle quitte l'éditeur Jean-Paul
Enthoven pour aller avec son fils
Raphaël Enthoven Jean Sarkozy qui
accompagnait son père dans tous ses
déplacements restera désormais à la
maison
[Applaudissements]
elle
était là
l'intimité du Président c'est fini les
premières photos de Carla à l'Élysée
circule la chanteuse est assise sur le
pouf préféré de Bernadette Chirac
Bernadette qui a toujours refusé de
poser en nuisette et c'est tant mieux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
grand froid je m'adresse au SDF qui ont
installé des tentes en bord de Seine et
qui se sont baignés dimanche Paris Plage
c'est fini il faut attendre ou prochain
[Applaudissements]
et puis fouiller un peu donnez-vous du
mal j'ai avec moi une annonce de
particuliers un particulier
alloué boulevard de Port-Royal très bel
appartement 190 mètres carrés vu
Luxembourg 6,30 € le mètre carré c'est
moins cher qu'une tente Décathlon et
vous demandez madame Boutin Christine
[Applaudissements]
Vanessa Paradis reçoit les insignes de
chevaliers des Arts et des Lettres c'est
normal car la Bruni première dame de
France tous les chanteurs s'envoient
seront décorés
[Applaudissements]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu